our vision for Android auto is to bring
a safe and seamless experience to every
car which means we provide a way for
people to connect their digital lives
seamlessly into the car so the same
absent services you use on your phones
and other devices are available just as
easily in your car if you attended our
session yesterday or have been paying
attention to what we've been up to
you'll know that we have to in car
platforms Android Auto and Android
automotive OS the first of these
platforms Android auto runs on the phone
and integrates with compatible cars
this means your apps and services will
be available on the screen in a driving
optimized way you can interact with
these apps through your car's screen and
controls but everything is running from
the phone we initially previewed Android
auto at i/o in 2014 and launched to
consumers in early 2015 we are proud to
say that Android auto is now available
in 36 markets in more than 500 different
car models from 50-plus brands and we
have thousands of apps already
compatible with Android auto and
continue to see growth in this area our
partnership with developers is a key
reason for the success of Android auto
and we hope to bring those apps to our
newest platform Android automotive OS so
the second platform Android automotive
OS is what we are going to talk about
today with automotive OS Android is
running as the embedded infotainment
platform in the car enabling a much
deeper more seamless experience from
everything from navigating with Google
Maps to listening to music with Spotify
to adjusting your climate temperature
and unlike Android auto the apps and
services are running directly in your
car
and it doesn't matter what kind of phone
you have we previewed automotive OS the
last couple years at i/o and announced a
few weeks ago that the first consumer
vehicle to launch with the embedded
platform will be available in the
Polestar to launching in 2020 and you
can check that out in our sandbox if you
haven't already so we hear from user
surveys that there are four key things
people like to do in the cars navigate
between locations communicate with phone
calls or messages listen to music via
Spotify and control various aspects of
the car such as adjusting their seat
position with a platform like Android in
the car we intend to enable app
developers to develop apps in many of
these categories in fact we anticipate
that you'll develop apps beyond these
categories and we want to enable you to
do that
thoughtfully and over time so today
we're gonna take you on a journey
through the app development process
starting with design so we know that the
automotive space is very complex there
are a myriad of screen sizes shapes
resolutions different input modalities
and countless regulations and we know
that we want to prioritize the driver
their primary responsibility is to focus
on the road everything else is secondary
so the first vertical which we want to
enable is media and we have borrowed a
lot of learnings from Android auto over
the past few years where the user
experience is developed by Google in
collaboration with app developers and it
will be customizable by car makers so
media will enable developers have a
consistent experience across Android
auto and Android automotive OS so that
the two platforms are similar it will
enable developers to maintain their apps
branding not worry about driver
distraction or making sure that it works
across the maryadas screen
sizes and for car makers it will allow
them to customize the media experience
based on the system design and branding
so now I'm going to walk through four
key themes that we think about when
designing for automotive these are the
principles that we used in order to
design for media the best part is as
developers you don't have to worry about
any of these and I'll go through these
in detail so the first theme is our
driver distraction guidelines they take
the complexity out of designing for
automotive here's a sample of what we
consider information should be timely
and relevant targets should be easy to
touch and we shouldn't distract the
driver with complex animation or video
and we want to encourage people to keep
their hands on the wheel so the second
theme is our adaptive framework and as I
mentioned earlier the car landscape
isn't getting any simpler so we're
working with car makers globally to roll
out a framework across their cars in a
way that keeps it consistent for
developers third is a voice optimized UI
which supports hands-free driving with
features like voice optimized search
with speech to text and the Google
assistant which will provide users quick
access to apps and content without
having to interact directly with their
screens and finally we want to make sure
the content is recognized by your users
through the use of your apps branding
icon and colors so that's all the stuff
that we've done for you now I'm going to
talk about how to design media apps so
first define your architecture and
determine the primary navigation items
design an icon and label for each next
choose how you want your content to be
displayed should it appear in a grid or
a list this will likely be determined by
the type of content that you have
for example you may want to use a grid
for content across categories and you
may want to use the list to depict songs
in an album third customize your
playback controls such as forward and
back thirty Seconds a thumbs up or
thumbs down to signify like or dislike
and make sure you design your icons to
represent each state so fourth design a
sign-in screen if needed and we
recommend using a dark theme you may
choose to implement via sign-in you may
choose to implement sign-in via
bluetooth pin user name or password or
any combination of these next design
your settings and again we recommend
using design theme using a dark theme
for this settings should include things
like accounts and profile information
app preferences related to driving and
sign-in and sign-out functions and
finally provide your branding elements
an app icon which will be used on all
screens that depict content an accent
color which a car maker may choose to
implement navigation icons and labels
and any custom controls that you wish to
include so to recap we take care of
driver distraction so that you don't
need to worry about it we have an
adaptive framework that makes it so that
your content is displayed correctly
across screens we optimize for voice to
make driving safe and we make sure that
your brand is recognized by your users
and designing for automotive is easy so
to get more details and more information
go to our UX guidelines in the link on
the screen so thank you very much now
that I've talked to you about designing
for media apps I'm going to hand it over
to Igor who's going to talk about
developing for media apps
[Applause]
thank you here hello everyone my name is
Igor resuming I might take lead working
on enabling applications to run in
android a the motive is so it's heaven
mentioned and drawing that emotive way
is is where your applications right
natively inside the car and phone is not
needed also she mentioned but we are
taking care of some driver distraction
so you don't have to so my part of the
talk is going to be about what you is a
developer need to do to enable your
application in require and we are
starting with media apps so first of all
Android at the Moriya basis is different
platform but it is very similar to
Android other when it comes to
integrations of media apps in fact we
kept almost all integration points from
Android auto to Android automotive is so
let me go through steps what you need to
do to enable your application for a car
well first of all you need to build your
outdoor service and this part would talk
I'm not going to explain to you how to
do because it's totally on you if your
application uses Google Play services
that's great because you still can use
them because we kept them in the car as
well we removed some models but didn't
make sense in a car but if if you remove
something that we deeply care about
please talk to us and we'll in consider
bringing back some some of Google Play
services models we already adapted for a
car like fins with heavy UI you'll be
already running on the car and we'll
have UI which is themed for a specific
car so now step two is familiar for for
those of you who already did the patient
one droid era you need to integrate with
media session and implement Media
Browser service and media session is
basically how you control your music way
back previous next way and this will how
it will be integrated with car hardware
Media Browser service is needed if you
want to expose a content
but you want to provide a user to play
so this is how you build your three
structure but user can navigate a finite
music to play or write podcast to play
so if you integrate it we went through
an arrow this is you already done it so
all these steps we already covered in
our previous sessions there's plenty of
documentation online and our developer
site how to do it
alright some specifics when you
integrate in media sessions specifically
from a car well first of all when your
service is created you need to create
media stations immediately so it will be
ready to play when the car starts and to
prepare music to play faster anyway then
when the user hits wiki so you react to
on prepare and you set your media
session to state post don't need to
start playback automatically work car
will tell you when when it's ready to
play because it keeps the state of what
was happening music if if user posted
before leaving the car or if user was
playing when when we left the car and
also where framework will remember which
application was playing the media last
time so it will resume exactly the same
application when driver gets back into
the car
so to recap with these two steps
building a service and implementation of
mini session and Media Browser service
is exactly same steps but you would have
done for integrating live Android era so
it should be known to you so now let's
talk about things but a new of the
specific for Android at a more aware yes
first of all you need to declare your
application what is done for for cars
and this is pretty simple you just add
these two lines to your manifest and
you're done this way also have a Play
Store in the car will recognize with
your application is done for a car and
it will be available for users to
install next step is it could be easier
could be hard if your application is a
refactored or area but you playback
service
separate from your user interface you
just need to exclude your mobile
activities from a packet what you're
going to be making for a car because my
Bell activities are not designed for a
kind we're not they're a distraction
optimized so we will not be allowed in
the car except if a couple of exceptions
we're not going to talk later one more
exception is sending activity because
you don't have your phone to start
playing in the car you need your user to
sign in somehow and so you implement
activity which is designed for a car and
the way since you don't have any other
activities you don't launch it yourself
well framework you launch it for you
another way you do it you you will set
an arrow state on media session and you
set specific extra we've give content
result we've give a resolution intent to
take you to a sign-in activity so you
set extra and you set a playback session
into error state saying authentication
required settings activity is optional
if if you need to control playback for
example maybe you need to download music
and you need to set back quality
settings activity is optional way you
declare it it's it's pretty standard you
just say internal filter applications
preferences and this will be
automatically recognized by the platform
itself and it will display an icon so
user can go to settings sign-in and
setting the activity we had driver
distraction not optimized so we only be
allowed when the car is parked all right
some things to consider when you
implement in your activities don't set
them to any specific orientation you
can't rotate your car avoid using
notifications notifications that
distract not optimized for the riving so
in the user might mission so only
important if ik
we'll be displayed when the user is
diving and everything else just be
mindful when using notifications so
what's even harder to see in a car
because there is focusing on the road
mostly so don't use toast we in the
future we might have been disabled on
permissions
also like not really a great idea to ask
them as a user is driving to ask for
permissions if you absolutely have to
ask for permission do it in your
settings and sign-in activity and a car
screens could be very large so if you
provide graphics to infotainment system
provide all the vector images were
possible because some screens are very
large and your bit maximum might not
look very great so so let's recap so you
build your audio service which you
probably already know how to do it you
implement media session and media's or
Media Browser service interfaces and you
implement all the steps but I was
talking about with a specific for a car
so now Roberta is going to talk to you
about tools what we building for working
with applications for cars and he also
go for some practical demo how to build
a music application for for a car Thank
You Igor
my name is Berta Parris and I'm going to
walk you through the changes we have
done to the Android development tools to
support automotive OS some of the
changes we've done are on Android studio
what we have included there are new code
templates that are going to allow you to
develop for automotive voice more easily
the first template I want to talk is the
new project template this is going to
create a project that contains support
for both Android auto and automotive
voice and it also includes an escalator
on of a media service
you will have to do the work of
implementing your business logic and
your your streaming but it's going to
give you a framework where to start the
second template is a new module
automotive template this is in the case
that you already have an application and
this application already implements all
the necessary pieces for Android auto
and you want to extend it to support
automotive OS the template is going to
add a new module the declarations to
indicate that this application is meant
to be run on a car and you can then
connect it to your existing business
logic now when it gets to the point of
testing your code we don't expect you to
go and buy a cars to be able to test it
the best option is to use an Android
emulator and to that end we are
including two new virtual devices that
you can use the first one is at cleric
automotive oil spiritual device these
contains reference implementation of the
media experience and live act services
and sorry Google Play services and all
the necessary pieces for you to be able
to test your application you can also
see the same system image in the code
labs here in i/o where you can play with
it the second virtual device is actually
provided by Volvo is the same experience
that you're going to see in the poster
to car you actually can see this in
action in our garage and it contains the
poster version of the media experience
instructions on how to download it and
install it or in the link on the screen
and of course as we introduce new
features more form factors come into
play
different screen sizes we're going to be
updating the list of emulators the tools
I just described are available today as
part of the Android studio 3.5 beta just
a note the automotive features are
hina feature flag instructions on how to
enable them are on the link on the
screen so now is time to do some demo
and from their work that Igor presented
the the three steps on how to build a
media app I'm going to focus on the
third one the automotive eight specific
features so to fast-forward my demo I'm
going to start from an existing project
this project is a simplified version of
the universal media sample app this
sample application is provided by Google
is publicly available on github it
contains all the pieces of a complete
media application it has a streaming
implements media session meter browse so
I'm going to start from here and I'm
going to use the and they understood
your template to ask automotive support
I'm going to test it on the emulator and
in the end we're going to have a fully
flesh media application running on
automotive OS so now if we can switch to
my laptop so this is my project
it contains two modules one of them is
mobile this module contains all the
assets for the phone so it contains
sign-in activities all the activities
that you see on the phone and is the one
that generates the apk that powers
Android auto the second module is it's
called media
it contains a music service which does
all the business logic for playback and
implementation of media station and
media browse
so as you can see I'm starting from a a
good place it contains all the pieces
for supporting Android auto so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to extend it to
support automotive oil I'm going to use
the new module template I'm going to
select automotive
and I'm going to completely form the
first thing I need to give my
application a name this is the name that
is going to appear to the users on the
app selector and then to say oral this
is the fake application name we've been
using for the demos I'm going to rename
my module automotive to make it clear
that this is where all the automotive
specific things are going to go like all
the vehicle optimized activities and
assets and I need to change my package
name to match the code that I already
have the wizard is going to ask me if I
want to create a new media service and
the truth is we already have one in the
share module so I'm going to say no and
now we just need to wait for Gradle to
do its thing and we get our third module
if we look a little deeper we can see
that this manifest includes the
declarations to say that this is an
automotive OS application but my module
is empty there's there is no code here
and that's because we said we are going
to reuse the content of the media the
media module that we already have so for
that I need to add a dependency I'm
going to add a line to this Gradle file
and this is going to tell the automotive
module to reuse the media service that
we we have on the media module Maya
media module uses Java so I also need to
copy this declaration over there and
that's it this is all the code I need to
have an automotive OS application now in
order to test it I said before the best
option is to use an emulator and this is
where we added some new features to
undress to do we have a new section
automotive and here's where we have the
two new virtual devices so I'm going to
complete this wizard and we have a new
virtual device ready to launch so here
we have the emulator running well this
is booting I'm going to complete my my
code all I need to do is to compile it
now you're going to notice there is this
red cross here and that's because
Android studio is complaining that there
is no activity to launch and that's
actually by design because in our case
this application doesn't have a launcher
activity and the application is going to
be launched by the media experience by
the system so I'm going to select no
nothing here so this is going to tell us
to do to just compile and install it but
not to launch it and I want to show you
the media experience these are the
applications we have by default and if I
if I compile we just need to wait a
couple of seconds
and this to you just told me that is
compiled successfully and installed
successfully so now we have our new
application here if I click on it we
have an application working I can select
a song this is going to start playing
and we have our application working on
automotive OS
I want to show these same application
how it looks on the poster so I'm going
to select the poster - and I'm going to
launch that that virtual device what is
what this is putting we can start
compiling again I need to wait
okay
application is ready and we can see the
same application how it looks at little
different because this is using the
customizations that Bo has done on their
own system okay and that's the demo can
we switch back to the presentation
okay that way well thank you
now with our code ready we are ready to
publish our application and for that
what we're going to be using is using
app bundles our bundles is a format that
allows you to package all your assets
both for the phone and for the car in a
single package that you can upload to
Google Play Store then Google Play Store
is going to take care to distribute the
corresponding package to each device
this is going to streamline the way you
manage your uploads Google Play Store is
going to start receiving submissions
later this year so to summarize I want
to give you a raw map depending on where
you are on your development process
let's say that you're starting from
scratch you don't have an application
yet then there are two options were to
start one is you can use the templates
that I show you on Android studio this
is going to give you the skeleton they
did necessary structure to start from
but you will have to implement all their
business logic yourself the other option
is to start from the other end that is
using this universal media player sample
app this contains all the code it
implements support for all the form
factors in Android including automotive
OS and it has all the implementation and
solutions for common problems while
dealing with media then maybe you really
have an application but it doesn't
implement media service yet so you can
use the automotive media service
template this is going to give you the
skeleton of a media service it's going
to add it to your project you will need
to hook
to your existing business logic or maybe
you already have an Android auto
application but it's built as a
monolithic code base so in that case you
will need to work on modularize it and
by that I mean separating your phone
assets from the media service that way
you're going to be able to reuse your
media service for automotive if you go
to this point you're almost done
all you need to do is to add the
declaration to support automotive voice
and if your application needs sign-in or
settings you need to develop vehicle
optimized activities and configure it a
seeker explained before in the end we
expect the project's similar to this one
module dedicated to the phone that it's
going to power both the phone experience
and the and router experience and a
module for automotive that is going to
contain vehicle optimized assets meant
to be run on the car and then after
module containing most of your business
logic the implementation of media
session and mere browse as a share
module between the two we have added the
Android developers website we
instructions step us step by step
instructions on how to get this done and
if you want to get your hands dirty we
have the code labs here at i/o with this
little bench units where you can test
create an application from scratch later
today we're going to be hosting office
hours and we would love to hear from you
if you have any questions on what we
presented today or if you have any other
ideas on the automotive space we'll we
would love to hear you in the same area
we have two cars one of them is the
poster to running the system experience
that I presented before so come and see
automotive os in action so this is it
here are all the links that I we
presented during today's session we're
hoping to see your applications hitting
the road
thank you
coming
[Music]